hi this is kim from khan academy and did
you know that what we call the first
amendment today was actually the third
amendment in the original draft of the
bill of rights
in fact there were more than 200
proposed amendments which were whittled
down to just 12 that's right 12 not 10.
so
what were those two proposed amendments
that weren't ratified along with the
other 10 the unadopted amendments to
learn more i talked to fergus bordewick
he's a writer and historian and the
author of the first congress how james
madison george washington and a group of
extraordinary men invented the
government these unadopted amendments
which
weren't included in the bill of rights
aren't nearly as well known so what were
they
well to put it in context there were
more than 200 amendments originally
proposed during the first congress
james madison had the responsibility of
winnowing those 200 down to a manageable
number he compressed them finally down
to 19 then to 17 and finally to 12. 12
were approved by the first congress
10 of them are the ones that we today
call the bill of rights but nobody then
referred to them as the bill of rights
madison and other members of the first
congress refer to them as adjustments of
the constitution alterations of the
constitution
and sometimes as amendments but the term
bill of rights only came into use in the
20th century really i had no idea
members of the first congress often
talked about
the lack of a bill of rights
and they referred to bills of rights
that some states had
but
the first ten amendments to the
constitution were not treated as a bill
of rights in fact those who most wanted
a bill of rights said this isn't one
okay so we end up with 12 adjustments to
the constitution
but in today's bill of rights there are
only 10. so what were those other two
one of them had to do with the
apportionment of seats in congress how
many seats would there be and how many
people would each
member of the house of representatives
represent that was one amendment the
other had to do with the method of
providing salaries for members of the
senate and the house of representatives
all right so we have the text of these
two unadopted amendments here
one says
after the first enumeration required by
the first article of the constitution
there shall be one representative for
every thirty thousand until the number
shall amount to one hundred
after which the proportion shall be so
regulated by congress that there shall
not be less than 100 representatives nor
less than one representative for every
40 000 persons until the number of
representatives shall amount to 200
after which the proportion shall be so
regulated by congress that there shall
not be less than 200 representatives nor
more than one representative for every
50 000 persons
okay so it seems like the general gist
here is setting up a proportional
arrangement about the house of
representatives the other one is a
little bit shorter it says no law
varying the compensation for the
services of the senators and
representatives shall take effect until
an election of representatives shall
have intervened
so you can't change
how much
senators and representatives get paid
without an election in between so they
can't raise their own salaries so why
did these two amendments end up on the
cutting room floor
well bear in mind that both of these
were approved by congress
then they went after the states they had
to be ratified by the states the states
ratified the other 10 that we're all
familiar with they almost ratified the
amendment
having to do with the apportionment of
seats in congress
that ratification fell short by by one
state
the other one having to do with the
salaries of congress
although it was very uncontroversial
simply didn't generate enough interest
to be ratified the two amendments which
failed to be ratified were the only two
that strictly do not have to do with
rights
and i don't think that there was a very
passionate concern for them among the
voting public did the constitution need
to be amended in order to establish a
process for setting
members salaries well no it didn't it
didn't we know that it did not
was it necessary to amend the
constitution to
uh set a principle of apportionment
well apparently not and i think by and
large by and large americans
and our representatives recognize
principles that rise to the level of of
constitutional amendment
with respect to these two amendments
neither of them really has to do with
rights and that's why
we somewhat misunderstand them if we are
always referring to a bill of rights
because these two are not rights
they're essentially more in the order of
congressional housekeeping
there was virtually no debate in
congress at all about the proposed
amendment
that would
enable congress to
provide salaries for members
everybody thought this is a pretty good
idea
in in point of fact as we all know in
the 200 years plus since then
uh congressional salaries have been
raised by uh
legislation when when needed it turned
out that the amendment absolutely wasn't
necessary even though it was finally
ratified in 1992
now there was a great deal of debate
however over the apportionment of seats
in in in the house of representatives
in the first house of representatives
there were only 59 members they
represented districts of widely varying
size
for example
one representative from georgia
represented sixteen thousand people a
representative from the main district of
massachusetts maine was not a separate
state then
represented ninety six thousand the
debate
the sharpest debate was over how many
individuals would a given member of the
house represent they had to come up with
a number it wasn't obvious what the
numbers should be so the debate really
was over whether each representative
would represent 30 000 or 40 000 this
doesn't sound important today but our
country was much smaller obviously much
smaller and these were fairly big
numbers for the time
uh those who argued for
each representative
representing 30 000 wanted a larger
house of representatives it was a more
populist kind of idea the people who
argued most forcefully for it were
anti-federalists that's to say those are
the people who really didn't like the
constitution at all they didn't even
want it
they wanted what they saw as a
more
democratic house of representatives
more conservative members argued for a
smaller house of representatives
based on the idea that the larger it
would be the less manageable it would be
james madison himself was very hostile
to the idea of a larger house of
representatives arguing that it would be
a step towards tyranny because a body
too large would fall victim to
demagogues this is really fascinating
because even if we had gone with 30 000
or 40 000
today the house of representatives would
have more than 10 000 people in it but
today we only have
435 representatives in the house
so how did we get from there to here
well congress did provide for the
incremental increase in in
the size of congressional districts
knowing that population would increase
everybody knew was going to increase
nobody in 1789 or 1790 could imagine a
country of
200 million people the outermost number
that they contemplated
in 1790 was about 200 we now know it's
435.
over time in the 19th century as we
admitted more states we added more
population and more representatives the
politics of stopping it at 435 is
frankly a little intricate but at any
rate the number continued to increase
through the 19th century into the 20th
century there was no reapportionment
after the census of 1920. the
republicans who dominated in congress at
the time
uh
worried that uh
that reapportioning after 1920 would
increase the number of democrats
it became a partisan issue there was no
reapportionment
until later in the 1920s when it was
stopped at 435 and since then there's
basically been a consensus that this is
a manageable number
one of these amendments actually
reappeared and was passed in
1992. can you tell us a little bit about
the story of this lost amendment
yeah it's a cute story um
a a student at the university of texas
in the 1980s was writing a paper on uh
for a history class and and stumbled
across this long forgotten
amendment
and uh
wrote about it
and was given a i believe a c grade for
it because his professor considered the
subject
irrelevant and inconsequential
uh his name was gregory watson
and he was so i think frustrated by the
grade but also inspired by by by
the story of this forgotten amendment
that he
uh began to wage initially a a one-man a
one-student lobbying campaign
and uh astonishingly enough within a
decade nearly every state ratified that
amendment all but four states so it has
now since 92
been an amendment to the constitution
frankly and not a very relevant one
because congress has raised
congressional salaries by ordinary
legislation for more than 200 years
they didn't really need the amendment to
do so
looking back over the history of
constitutional amendments you see that
they kind of come in bunches
there are you know the the ten that come
immediately after the adoption of the
constitution
then there are the reconstruction
amendments that come right after the
civil war and then there are the
progressive era amendments ones like
prohibition or women's right to vote
then there's been kind of a
lull
in constitutional amendments this 1992
amendment is the 27th and final so are
there more amendments coming and
if so what might they be about
well it's very difficult to amend the
constitution that's one reason there are
so few there are other countries which
have immensely long constitutions and
amend them all the time we are extremely
conservative as as a nation historically
in tampering with or altering
uh our constitutions let's look at a
couple of recent ones there was the
equal rights amendment uh an amendment
to guarantee
across the board equal rights to women
which almost passed i believe it fell
short by only one state back in the
1970s and that came within a hair of
being
ratified another amendment that
had some vigor in it in in recent years
was one to
provide a voting member for the district
of columbia the district of columbia is
not a state
it's a unique entity the constitution
does not provide
for the seat of government to be a state
so it's very tricky legally and
constitutionally what is the district of
columbia
there was a proposed amendment that
would enable
d.c to have a voting member i think both
of these amendments which were proposed
but were not ratified may return
i do think at some point dc will be
given a status that enables it to have
voting representation in congress i'm
not sure what the formula will be there
is a renewed effort underway currently
to reintroduce the equal rights
amendment and i think as women
uh increasingly have a higher
profile and more more influence
politically
that the possibility of that one day
becoming a an amendment to the
constitution is is foreseeable one thing
that we haven't discussed so far is that
when the bill of rights originally was
passed it only applied to the federal
government not to the states how does
that intersect with these unadopted
amendments very important point
uh james madison
who did more
than any other member of congress to
shape what we now call the bill of
rights
madison argued that
these amendments should also apply and
especially the the
protections of civil rights that we find
in that for in the first amendment and
others that they should apply to states
he argued
vigorously
that they should be meant to apply to
states and he he failed he wanted
that to be explicit in the bill of
rights it is not
because the power of states rights
within congress was still so great in
1790 that
states would not accept it when did that
change
the reconstruction era amendments
designed initially to provide rights for
black americans for african-americans
coming out of slavery
made clear that the bill of rights
had to be applied
across the board in states was it
practically speaking no it wasn't in
point of fact it was those
reconstruction amendments were largely
disregarded and ignored for many many
years until the 20th century civil
rights movement particularly beginning
in the 1950s
began to put federal muscle behind the
enforcement
of those amendments and here we're
specifically discussing the 14th
amendment and its equal protection
clause which was passed after the civil
war to guarantee citizenship rights to
african americans but was really as we
know from the jim crow laws something
that existed on paper but not in reality
and it took the work of civil rights
groups and federal enforcement to make
these rights that existed on paper a
reality yeah absolutely absolutely
correct it's really a modern notion when
i say modern i mean a 20th century
notion that all americans
should expect to have
equal rights in practice under the law
in the 19th century equal rights were
not enforced regardless of what the
constitution or
the uh
bill of rights says
and uh without a federal government
committed to it they won't be enforced
so we've learned that there were more
than 200 proposed amendments to the u.s
constitution that james madison whittled
down to just 12 and of those only 10
were ratified at the time of the framing
the unadopted amendments show us just
how important ratification is to the
amendment process even if an amendment
is proposed and passed by congress or a
special convention of the states to
become law three quarters of the states
must ratify it which is really hard to
do what do you think the next
constitutional amendment will be the
equal rights amendment representation
for the district of columbia or
something completely different to learn
more about the bill of rights check out
the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics